so this is a kind of a weird jumping-off
point but I listen to you on I think it
was a Mother Jones podcast and you very
briefly mentioned a machine learning
experiment for the audiobook yeah could
you talk about that a little bit longer
sure yeah of course um well okay so the
background is that as I've been working
on these books that are in a lot of ways
traditionally published even though I
have an interesting very sort of
forward-thinking publisher and CD they
still get printed on paper and you know
sold mostly in bookstores and online and
places like that as I've been working on
all that stuff for a few years now I've
also like many people in this area many
people that I'm sure you guys know I've
been really interested to the to the
point of sort of preoccupation with
machine learning yeah in particularly
the creative applications like less this
super practical sort of uses and the
ways that it might transform the economy
and all that and I mean truly more like
the ways that we can use some of these
systems to mash and mangle and and just
interact with like words and pictures
and sounds in different ways so that's
all preface the audio book first of all
it's actually interesting to know for
folks that aren't totally plugged into
the publishing industry audiobooks are
huge it's like they're growing like
gangbusters every time I go to a
bookstore and do a reading I ask people
like how many of you also listen to
audiobooks and I mean truly everybody's
hand goes Wow it's like just a really
really popular way to consume this media
so kind of in step with that audiobook
producers have gotten really serious and
frankly a little bit demanding they're
like okay mr. Sloan it's time to produce
the audio book what do you got for me
you know like what can you produce or
what will you produce that will make
this little distinct from just the
printed book they don't want to just do
like a recitation of what's on the page
so for this book
sourdough the story happens to hinge on
this sourdough starter you know this
little funny community of microbes that
you used to bake this delicious bread
and in the story there's a starter with
some strange properties and there's also
this singing there's like this music
that I don't want to give any spoilers
but it kind of helps the starter grow
and it's all part of this mysterious
package so I describe the music over and
over in the book I mean like a great
length like oh it's so slow and sad and
mysterious like in a language that no
one understands and so come time to
produce the audiobook I was like if you
go through this whole thing in your
earbuds and you never hear even a scrap
of this music like it's gonna be kind of
disappointing unfortunately we did not
have the budget to like hire the people
who invent Dothraki Thrones or Klingon
or whatever so we need some other way to
like synthesize this sound that would be
truly alien like it is it's not any
language on planet earth it's something
fictional something invented so this
where it loops back around to that
obsession with machine learning as I
think you guys probably know one of the
things that that these models can do
really well is sort of take a corpus of
stuff of you know training material and
extract some patterns or general
patterns and then use those to generate
something new but different you know not
just kind of mimicry of what you put in
so I mean at that point it actually you
know it took a lot of kind of learning
and tinkering with the code actually
struggling with the code at this point
or flow or this was in actually funnily
enough this program was in Lua in TOR -
the original torch and totally a
testament to just the power of this open
source ecosystem I mean this was a paper
written by one group of researchers
implemented by this like rogue mad
machine learning genius UK this kind of
Richard SR who's just like I like bowed
down to him and his generosity truly and
like making this really wonderful and
very useable implementation of this tool
it's called sample rnm and it takes as
many mp3s as you want to feed it chops
them up into bits churns learning for
days and days and days at least on my
deep learning rig I'm sure Google would
be like got it for me it took a few days
and then in the end spits out this this
really to my you're at least weird and
and lovely to kind of generalization you
know it tries its hardest to learn the
essence of that music you fed it of
course it kind of fails because
nowadays models are actually that good
yet at least had stuff of that level of
complexity but the way in which I fail
is really interesting so that's all the
same that now in this audio book there
is just these little whispers of this
fictional music in this fictional
language and to my knowledge is the
first time that like the creative output
of a machine learning system has been
included in an audio book I mean I think
it might be a tiny distinction but I am
all about tiny distinctions I will like
I just want to rack up all the like tiny
steps for words the state of the art
have you used the model to create
anything else oh yeah I mean basically
when after you've assembled one of these
rigs or a couple of them in my case um
you feel bad about ever letting them sit
idle because I mean that's what they're
for they've got these big beefy GPUs and
and it's so hard and truly it's so hard
to get all the weird little libraries
and dependencies all lined up right so
at having like done that you never want
to let them sit so yeah like I have some
models that are kind of always turning
on different bodies of text you know
just to try to see what happens and what
emerges but there's one where I've
thrown in all sorts of different kinds
of music and sound just to see what it
sounds like on the other end and sure
enough I mean sometimes what comes out
is just kind of a messy garble and
sometimes it's really interesting we
listen to it on sound phone no no you
can listen to it on the sourdough audio
book which is available on audible.com
but no none of the other stuff is public
yet it's not quite it's the other stuff
is still at the level of you know and a
lot of this stuff is it's kind of I
think in this state it's like that's
sort of frothy frumenty experimental
like ooh there's like something there
mmm but I personally don't quite know
what that something is and so a lot of
my work with this machine learning stuff
is kind of trying to push through that
to get to like you know a thing like a
thing that's actually worth sharing on
the other end and that is definitely a
working partner and what were the input
files
in this case it was almost like a short
circuit straight from my own inspiration
to the output because of course you know
this all started this project was only
necessary um or you know I only sort of
thought to do it because I had written
about this fictional music and
decisional language in my book and that
came from my own experience listening to
a kind of music that I've just long
enjoyed and sort of thought was
beautiful it's a kind of Croatian folk
singing all a cappella sort of a chorus
of voices in sort of odd harmonies it's
called klaapa que la pa and so I just
had my like you know folder pre-existing
folder of just all the klaapa mp3s I'd
ever how did you come across kalapa
because who knows on the Internet I mean
that's like always the answer to that
question yeah somewhere on the Internet
and it's just like for years I just I'd
long loved it and thought it sounded
lovely and so of course it was in my
brain when I'm when I'm imagining this
stuff and putting into my book and so
then in a way I mean this might be
reaching a little too far but I kind of
feel like the machine learning system
and I did the same thing just on
different tracks like input right and
like the experience of listening to
something followed by some munging
mashing step and in kind of abstraction
step of course in mind I kind of had my
response reaction in the music and the
girl network had a different thing going
on but then in the end we both spit out
something actually something new and
different
I mean transformed but still obviously
based on that on that same input and and
did you educate yourself similar around
robotic arms we've done all these like
basically technical adviser interviews
for TV shows and movies and stuff and I
was researching her the other day hoping
that there was someone there and Spike
Jones explicitly said we don't want a
technical adviser because I don't want
to be bounded by reality yeah I just
want to go for it that's awesome
actually I mm-hmm I wonder I don't know
if I'd like that or not I think I don't
actually I I think there's probably I
respect the people who are able to like
dive deep and nerd out with the experts
and remain unbound like you have to sort
of say you have to be sort of greedy and
like take everything that they tell you
they'd be like who
gotta go you know and into the realm of
imagination and strangeness and wonder I
feel like that's because I feel like
that's sort of self-serving because I
feel like that's sort of my model I do
love to read about this stuff I do not
own a robot arm of my own um I've never
personally operated one but I have seen
them operated and I think they're pretty
amazing I state not just you know like
mechanically or sort of yeah computation
like aesthetically I think they're
really interesting and lovely and and
yeah and so the the inclusion of lots of
robotic arms and people talking about
robotic arms and thinking about robotic
arms in this book was definitely was
driven just by my own yeah interest in
that's a great thing about living the
Bay Area and also just frankly the level
of tech journalism that exists today
yeah boy you can glean a lot and not
just surface level stuff but like the
really deep mechanics just by reading on
the internet and and kind of going down
this rabbit holes YouTube right like
anytime you want to go beyond these sort
of description be like okay well what
does it really look like or like how
does it how does it swivel in space I
mean there's a YouTube video to show you
it's amazing but then okay so to give
away a little bit of the book she Louis
gets the sourdough starter she
eventually starts making it herself she
ends up in this kind of hidden farmers
market and part of her part of her store
is like making the sourdough with the
robotic arm right and quarter that is
cracking the eggs is that a real
technical problem that exists um that's
a good question I don't know for sure I
suspect I call it like the egg problem
yeah capital e capital think it's like
you like I get all these roboticists are
like yes the all that stands between us
and domination of all the world's
economy is AGI then the egg problem yeah
exactly and I so I don't know I kind of
suspect that it is a problem it has been
my perception I could be wrong this is
probably where it buzzes into into
fiction a little bit but it has been in
my perception that um as as a character
in the book says you know there's
something really appealing about these
arms working in kitchens like
I mean they're just you're like we will
have done something when an arm can like
make you an omelet or do some of those
kitchen tasks but in fact it's really
challenging because that kitchen space
is in fact really chaotic and unbound it
it's not one of these spaces that sort
of at least a normal kitchen like a
restaurant kitchen or our home kitchen
McDonald's obviously is kind of kind of
into something around sort of modularity
and it's already pretty robotic to start
with but those other kind of kitchen
there's more organic kitchens if you
actually kind of do that thing of like
Dee familiarizing it and like looking
trying to look at everything in that
space and the way it all works together
with fresh eyes you're like that's
[ __ ] impossible it's just the angles
and the slopes and everything's a weird
shape and you can't recognize it all in
in I do think that's wonderful
that's lovely that it's like oh man what
a what a magic show actually for a human
cook to manage all those things at once
and then reach over and just with one
hand go and crack an egg yeah so yeah
well because you kind of you spoke to it
in the book around having two hands
basically like I can't do that either
I've tried it today like oh yeah this
will be easy just crack an egg with one
hand no not so much I will tell you that
you can learn it is at YouTube once
again is your guide I think in the book
if I remember right I actually have um I
have Louis learned by watching YouTube
clips including some that are so good
they're just because again truly
everything everything you need to know
and every task no matter how small is
somewhere like documented on YouTube and
and often it'll be like these
disembodied hands just it'll the video
is like a minute long and they just kind
of show you and demonstrate and do a
test run and then you know tap it on the
edge and it comes right open and I was
skeptical at first but in fact it is not
that hard hmm
right on yeah what was the inspiration
to do this book inspiration to do this
book was you know it's actually a lot
like the other books I've done it's
really living here in the Bay Area which
I I mean truly think it sounds a little
dorky almost a little Pollyannish but
much but but truly I just I've for all
for all of its complexity and problems
and everything else I think it's just a
really really inspiring place I think
it's a place where people do interesting
things and end up leading these really
interesting
and so yeah over the last few years I
personally just as a human had gotten
have gotten pulled more into the world
of food just as an observer kind of just
like someone curious about it and slowly
as a more of a participant although I'm
still much more of a observer than a
participant and it's just I mean this is
what happens with everything I think it
happens to journalists too you dip a toe
and do something and you realize that
it's just full of story I mean there's
so much stuff there's so many little
dramas and mysteries and and mechanics
that you can pretty easily turn into
into plots that's one of my questions is
that your stories from penumbra to
sourdough and of explore the
intersection between you know tech and
startups and old crafts like bread
making or in a book selling and so what
about that interaction is particularly
interesting to you well you know I think
it's some it's it's at the conjunction
between them and it the the honest
answer might be annoyance I'm so
routinely annoyed when the old and the
new get framed as an adversarial
relationship basically when people say
or or versus this habit and you know of
course this happens with books and it
was so much the sort of conversation
especially on like ebooks and print
books like the internet and the old
school publishing like well which will
it be you know which will triumph or
like what is the road forward and I
don't know why I don't know if it's just
temperamental or I've had good mentors
and good advisers or you know I've had
the opportunity to read smart thinkers
for a long time that has always seemed
so nonsensical to me like it seems to me
like it is always and instead of the new
thing replacing the old thing it all
just piles up in this like multi-car
crash non violent crash glorious crash
where everything is just everything is
just kind of like and the mountain is
getting higher and higher and higher and
I don't know I find that totally
exciting because it means we get new
things all the time but we also get the
benefit of crafts and ideas and
obsessions that have been sort of
compelling people for a really long time
so I
mostly not mostly but at least in in
large part my books are intended as a
sort of rebuttal to all the people who
want to make us choose between the old
and the new I'm like nope I want both
option see ya do you have a name for the
genre that you exist in because I was
talking to cat before about this and
there seems to be you know increasing
amounts possibly infinite amounts of
dystopian like black mirror type content
but you're kind of into this like
positive satire genre what do you call
that oh man I don't know it's a short
answer some someone did suggest genre
tag that I quite liked and they said I
think your books are sort of like puzzle
fiction and I just like the sound of
that I'm not sure that it's an actual
genre or even if my books are that
puzzling but I was like if I ever saw my
books on a shelf labeled puzzle fiction
I would be very happy there
I mean in my heart they are sci-fi
inflected literary fiction and all I
mean by that is I try to take care with
the sentences and just you know produce
language and you know scenes that are
like interesting somewhat interesting to
read and not just like glop on the page
at the same time there's no denying that
my core genre as a reader is science
fiction and so that stuff just gets kind
of metabolized and regurgitated I guess
or transformed it's refreshing yes sort
of like an on dystopic like they're
funny you know elements like the slurry
drinking that I definitely personally
recognize but but I think it's there
there I get an overall a positive sense
about the world you're building yeah
yeah I would say so I mean part of that
for me is root and this is not
necessarily a sort of dystopian or not
distinction but part of that for me is
rooted in the desire to have like
narrators and other characters that you
actually want to spend time with and
that's only because my most memorable
experience is a reading from you know
early childhood onward had been ones
where I finished the book you know
closed the back cover and I missed the
the mind that I was spending
with and there's a lot of good books
that are you know compelling engrossing
and rewarding that aren't that we were
like you know like what a bunch of
broken humans I mean there's a lot of
stuff like that books and and TV like
I'm probably probably more that than
anything else maybe it's actually for
exactly that reason and I'm like okay
cool other writers have got that unlock
they've got the like everyone is broken
beat nailed down and so maybe I'm gonna
do that thing that I like so much which
is you know voices that that you miss
know I love it because I'm I was talking
once to a YC founder and he was saying
you know if you talked to the vast
majority of founders in Silicon Valley
they were influenced by things like Star
Trek or Hitchhiker's Guide and these are
all like pretty rosy visions of the
future whereas you know right now we
have black mirror and all there's like
really dark stuff you know what is going
to be built twenty years from now and
the young people reading this and
watching this
that's a good question boy you know and
I feel like that should almost be like a
challenge I would that's a great sort of
like challenge to the science fiction
writers working today and I think some
of them by the way are at meeting that
challenge challenge I think people like
Cory Doctorow Anna Lee Nuits here in San
Francisco is amazing science fiction
writer
they don't write dystopias they don't
write those sort of you know naive and
glossy answers either like and guess
what it all worked out great
like just like that's not actually
useful either but yeah to find a path
through the the thorn enos of real life
and in power and you know the way that
people inflict pain and other people but
still remain kind of like wow excited
about what's coming next
yeah I do I think that's I mean it is
it's what I like to read and I hope
that's what people are they're still
producing it well I mean even in a
couple of interviews I've read with you
and listen to you were influenced by
children's books okay on your read you
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
specifically mention oh yeah for
sourdough in particular there is a great
genre of this is even this the genre is
very specific talk about specific
specific little slices of books this is
the sort of like runaway mutant
food genre chance of meatballs you got
your strega nona stinky cheese man yeah
absolutely
lesser-known lesser-known book called a
Datchet the Duchess makes a cake also
great and basically it's like all like
food that you know grows out of control
becomes giant and there's clearly
something that like resonates deeply
with the child's mind because it's like
you could totally populate a shelf with
those books man and were you reading
these beforehand or you're just like mmm
I think this needs to go a little
further I I can't say that those were
the direct influence for this book that
was more of a kind of hook shot where
after writing this book I was like oh
wait you know I think I think this has a
lineage the the more direct influence
for for that kind of stuff in sour dough
that kind of like a food vibe was truly
it's all the scholarship that's been
done in the last few years you know five
years maybe going on a decade about
microbes and the microbiome and just the
daily near daily wonder of like oh let's
see what's in the news today microbes do
what like think what huh they talk to
you and they're controlling my and
there's how many and we don't even know
I mean it's like I truly it's amazing
that's got to be such a fun discipline
to be in now and and for the last little
while
and yeah so that was I was like yes I
need to put some characters in this book
that are not people mom but microbes or
microbial communities and try to try to
give them some personality on the page
and did you think at any point you
wanted to make an app as well what for
this book for sour yeah well could you
know you're talking about staying around
with these characters and I use fish a
long time ago because when I actually
sat next to Patrick Moberg while he was
building it as I was working on a bait
works oh my gosh he's gonna get out of
my life man but uh I just been wondering
like if you would consider building some
kind of extension I I'd not considered
it for this book I you know there's a
thing you hear where people say like
okay you have to come up with a story
and then you find the right vessel for
that story like does this story want to
be a book or a video game or HBO series
whatever I think that is wrong I do not
think that's actually
how good things get produced so if you
ever hear someone say that you can tell
them robbing stones [ __ ] I think it's at
least for me I and I'll speak I'll speak
actually just for myself it's almost
exactly the opposite
you get interested first in a format
neither just you know four out of pure
kind of like childlike interest like oh
that comic book was so good or like wow
an amazing movie or like even like that
YouTube video was so weird and like
creepy whatever it is and then at some
point you start to sort of feel that
itch of like oh maybe I could make one
too you know maybe I could play in that
sandbox you can trace everything I've
ever made whether it's a book or a weird
digital experiment to that impulse of
truly starting with some form that I
admired and thought was awesome and then
trying to figure out like what what kind
of fits in that box so that's all to say
that this book came out of a sort of a
book shaped impulse and yeah I think the
next app is going to come out of an app
shaped impulse have you had any impulses
since like what's the next form I don't
know I definitely have I mean too many
that the problem is you're like there's
so many cool things I will tell you that
I'm I'm kind of still in I feel this
like tension it's totally unresolved I
don't have like plan a theory solution
or anything like that
but the app thing right now it's it's
super well you know I'll make it really
practical this is what happened I made
this app called fish mm-hmm several
years ago totally on a lark I mean
because I kind of admired the iPhone
screen in particular the like lack of
avro of browser tabs across the top or
like other windows tiled in the
background you know like it's it is the
it is the case that often more often
than on laptops and other things people
will just do one thing on an iPhone at a
time and that's actually really lovely
anyways
thought I'd take advantage of that made
this app is great well received I had a
lot of fun making it
years ago by the newest version of iOS
something has changed and now that like
the binary that I uploaded to Apple all
those years ago will not run anymore it
was it was getting a little funky like
it looks sort of weird on the newer
iPhones but you could still run it now I
am alerted by Apple an email it's not
going to run anymore because I am a
writer and
and not a professional software
developer I could not immediately find
the source code to this app and I read
it around and liked I got some old
laptops and I booted him up and I was I
just searched everything I checked my
email I was like surely I must have
emailed it to someone I can't find it
anywhere so I think it's gone and that
bums me out
what's had it is sad so I fear as of
this moment I my current thought is that
fish is lost to the world or at least
users of iOS iOS 11 and above and and
but there's actually something I mean
that's just my sort of carelessness
which is a bummer but there's actually
something embedded in that which is you
make these digital things and unlike a
book where once you bind it up and put
it on a shelf even if it gets forgotten
even if it gets damaged or you know
whatever it's like still X it boots
somehow you can you can like compile and
run at that printed book basically
forever and boy that is just not the
case with digital stuff like the ground
shifts under your feet and suddenly the
platform you built it on goes at a
business or you know the OS gets
upgraded and you're like the api's are
different and that's unsettling and to
sort of figure out how to navigate that
how to still embrace the fun of those
digital experiments but like not sign up
for infinite ongoing maintenance for
like an ever-increasing number of
projects I just don't know so that's
it's one of these I'm really thinking
about right now I think it's a it's very
distinct from the way that frankly
people in like companies would think
about making and maintaining apps but
there's plenty of people out there who
aren't people like me who are kind of
just tinker's experimenters writers and
artists and I think it's kind of a funny
moment for that kind of work right now
well if you actually look around it most
people who work in the tech energy
industry a lot of the work does fall
away like if you spend two years working
at Facebook or Twitter or Google yeah a
lot of your work is gone right six
months after you totally necessarily -
maybe the question is how do you give
something like an everlasting life
online right right I think it is such a
big question I mean there's stability
comes it seems at least partially with
time I mean if I was gonna make a
webpage say J and not a fancy one like a
real simple one
and then if I took that webpage and I
made sure to kind of have it host in a
few different places but it but it's a
it's up experiment say it's a story and
it's presented in some cool way and
there's a few kind of interactive bits
in JavaScript say you know as the page
proceeds and I host went on my website
and maybe I host went somewhere else and
I also make sure that it's indexed by
the Internet Archive I still don't feel
as good about that as I do about a
printed book on a shelf but I feel
pretty good about it I mean I think
there's like you're like okay web pages
have been around for what like yeah 30
years now like finally we can kind of
count on this technology continuing to
be legible and accessible but at the
same time you're like that's not the
most exciting thing like you don't I
can't make a cool mobile I don't know
like a are enabled experience with a web
page really not in the way that I would
want to and so there's basically I think
there is this trade-off and maybe it's
really natural between that sort of like
bleeding-edge coolness and
interestingness and that's sort of
stability and I don't know I don't know
if it's just like the archive or I don't
know you want to be able to share with
people a lot of now is just falling into
the hands of basically archivists in
museums yeah so you see it's happening I
think rhizomes doing a project to
preserve digital art yeah but you
basically are like buying you know Adele
from 96 and like butta yeah and like ear
gapping it and making sure that the
automatic like OS updates never totally
do not connect to the internet totally
totally it will somebody somebody I mean
yeah the museums have this collections I
would love to imagine there's someone
somewhere that's just like yes I have
like the menagerie every computer every
OS like what's that you need a mecca C
running OS 7.2 I've got one of those
Boop fire it up
well it's a big thing in tv2 we did I am
a podcast with Cortana from mr. robot
and it's so funny because their show is
only set two years ago but they're still
trying to keep like a consistent date
line so they're actually having to get
apps from like two years ago and then to
do the screenshots and the simulations
and they're like we can't even you can't
find like Facebook from to your ego
right that's that's admirable first of
all that is some that is some like 21st
century
Kubrick attention too nerdy to tell I
really appreciate that but it is it's
right it's it's a weird time I um I
would not bet against everything that
we're pouring into kind of the vast
digital box you know like everything the
Facebook updates the Instagram photos
all of it basically being gone in 2060
2050 like I hope that's not the case and
I mean it seems hard to believe because
it's like everybody's everything is in
these systems
but based on just what we know and the
way the patterns we've seen already I
like if we were like okay place your
bets I would be like and that will all
be deleted yeah speaking of deleting
Craig was telling me something that I
hadn't heard before that you have
written a script that deletes your tweet
oh yeah Wow and can you how did that
come about and why yeah oh no no this is
very this is very um clear-cut to me at
least
uh I I still love Twitter even though
Twitter is so fraught and so complicated
I started using it like a lot of people
kind of around 2009/2010 I worked it to
her for a couple years too and it was
very at that time like everyone who
worked at - it was like on Twitter
deeply and it was it was really pure fun
and I think it was because it was so
much more casual it was the era of like
grab understand which with at Craig and
at cat you know we're just so you're
like oh we were children then so things
have changed a lot but I but for me at
least I think there are some ways to
kind of anchor it in that other feeling
I like to think of Twitter as not like
sort of an ongoing transcript of a
congressional hearing you know to which
we can always return and be like well
actually catch four years ago you said
this and that was [ __ ] but rather as
like a huge weird interlinked
conversation in a cafe somewhere you
know people making bold claims and
referring to things and saying nice
things compliment each other then all of
it just kind of like fading into the
night air and it's gone like you
wouldn't you wouldn't record your cafe
conversation for
garetty I mean I mean if you would you
maybe some people do but that's weird
that's clearly like sort of strangely
antisocial I record everything and
transcribe it and index my whole life
yeah that's a that's a whole different
conversation but it is you you it is
like if that's actually quite strange
and yet it's the default for Twitter of
like recording everything and sort of
keeping it forever so that's all to say
my very tiny kind of lever against that
that system and my way of kind of
keeping it something like a cafe
conversation with the words just fading
away is to delete my tweets on the
regular and oh I can report that it
feels great that does sound quite
refreshing yeah yeah we're there any
like greatest hits here like a sad to
see it go it was I know it yes and it is
a good it's a healthy thing you can't
contend for a moat with your own vanity
and you're like oh but there's just so
many faves and but then it's gone you're
like I didn't need this face it's good
truly it's healthy it's a the burn it's
like a scalding sort of cleanse so this
brings me to one of my questions I think
I first came across you and when i was
reading snark market and so i loved it
because you know you would you know post
an essay and then it would kick off a
sort of discussion or debate below it
and sometimes they were sort of
contentious and and you came out reading
the essay feeling one way and then after
reading the comments or like oh no but i
see these other sides of it as well and
that died went in but 2050 i mean it was
like a lot of blogs it was just a sort
of slow tale off I mean I'm sure you
have never done this they would match
enimies they had to do it I'm sure you
could graph the post frequency and it
would be a real kind of actually a
slower ramp into this sort of bulging
sort of heyday and then a slow tail off
and furthermore I'll bet if you took
that and compared it to like average
hours employed per week by all snark
market authors it would be a perfect
sort of they would fit together like
puzzle pieces that makes sense I was
gonna ask if Twitter killed it I mean it
well it did it did in part boy I mean
that's just a whole thing a whole
melancholy story to kind of unspool the
story of blogs there's rise and fall of
blogs because I think people who
who kind of came up during that time not
only as bloggers but kind of as write
writers more broadly because it was it
was this amazing way to kind of cross
train and just force yourself to like
write something in public every day even
if you didn't like have it all perfectly
locked down or even or even know exactly
what you thought you're like well I'll
find out what I think by like starting
to write this little blog post in in my
movable-type installation it was it was
truly lovely but yeah there's no
question he was killed by Twitter and
Facebook and just really the sense that
people moved on I mean the reason you
wrote a post is because you knew people
would read it and some cases you knew
very specifically who would read it like
I remember in some ways the greatest
pleasure of writing for that blog I
understood our position exactly in like
the food chain of blogs we were not at
the bottom and in fact some of the
blog's we were reading we're like closer
to the bottom just in terms of number of
readers they were like super weird
specific itchy like strange little blogs
and and you would when you found one
that you liked you'd add it to your
google reader long lamented but I mean
that the loss of Google Reader it was
another true I mean truly was one of the
nails in the coffin of blogging but you
added you Google Reader and that became
part of your like secret stockpile and I
remember talking to people about feeds
and they would be cagey they'd be like
oh whatever it's just a just a scientist
feed I found somewhere it doesn't matter
do it
I'll blog the good stuff anyway just
you'd find interesting things you'd
write about it snark market was not top
tier I mean there's many sort of tiers
above us but there are a couple much
bigger blogs in particular and just you
know through the experience of linking
something and writing a little about it
and then maybe eight hours pass or a day
passes and then you see it at that next
blog up I began to understand very clear
I was like I knew our role in that
system in that sort of economy of ideas
and it was really cool it just felt
awesome to like have a place but um as
those readers go away like as basically
it's like there started to be these
holes in that mesh and then I think the
parts kind of shear off and then
disintegrate entirely and now I mean you
open up the squard press now you know we
did upgrade some
between 2008 and 2007 Dean and you open
up a little composition window and
you're like no one is gonna read this or
if they do it'll be only because I
essentially recreate it or give it a new
home on Facebook or Twitter mmm do you
have strong opinions on to 80 characters
I I do I do now um I I have to just
always remember this my first experience
with like user rage being an underaged
user that is to say it was in college my
first experience with high-speed
Internet and I loved in New York Times
website which was I mean it was probably
designed to be like 500 pixels wide at
that time it was just this tiny little
thing very proto you know web experience
but I loved it and in the early days
when things they did is they actually
you know to keep their time sness they
rendered all the headlines as images in
like The Times font because there
weren't like web fonts and they couldn't
do it justice they thought and so they
rented this as images and I thought that
was amazing I was saying for Horus their
images it's so beautiful it looks like a
newspaper so at one point very
reasonably they decided it's a little
weird and kind of rigid and inflexible
and probably you know he's wasting
people's bandwidth so he switched to
just normal text links and it was like
Times New Roman it wasn't a pretty fun
cuz again no web fonts yep so he
switched it and I wrote an email I was
probably a junior in college I think it
may concern their whom it may concern
you clearly don't understand your own
brand you've made a terrible mistake
with these ugly text links so dumb
literally 48 hours later I was like ah
man this page loads a lot faster now
this is great it was just a good
grounding early experience with like
come on Ernest change and you're gonna
be okay and so I have retained that
consciousness to this day and I was not
super upset about eternity characters
even though I of course like many of you
I appreciated the sort of the sort of
haiku constraints of 140 but I oh man I
love it
I just I just keep typing it's great and
someone made the point I thought this
was actually very super super sharp
there's you know a lot of different ways
to think about and talk about it someone
made the point
that with 280 characters it actually
gives you enough space it's not that
much space but it gives you enough space
to do something you almost never could
with 140 characters on their own which
is to present one idea kind of like set
up the thing and then turn it around
react to it you can basically say well a
lot of people say X but I think Y or you
could say like I used to think X and now
I think Y like there's enough space for
like two ideas to be in dialogue with
each other whereas before and after this
this it was like an academic who kind of
pointed this out I was like oh yeah
that's right before all tweets were like
blah here's the thing here's the thing I
mean even if it was a nice thing or a
funny thing they were just like blah but
now a tweet there is enough space for it
to be kind of a like hmm or like what
about and that might be healthy I think
hmm I don't know if any fewer people
will be taken out of context but it
makes sense I do appreciate the little
circle like progress thing rather than
the countdown right now those really
slick yeah yeah yeah is you get we've
been and it is like oh right I've been
playing a weird game this whole time I
didn't even realize like and as soon as
the numbers go away you're like didn't
matter
yeah so what are you excited about right
now are you thinking like all right I
mean maybe you've already sold a book
and I don't even know it yeah what are
you into
boy I'm into a lot of things I will say
that the machine learning stuff
continues to preoccupy me I think in
part because I think there's art there
continues to be an arbitrage opportunity
for artists or kind of art adjacent
people so much of the energy is focused
on super practical and like economically
valuable applications which is fine and
I totally you know I truly like I cannot
wait for self-driving cars to come fully
online and for robot arms to be doing
you know all sorts of tasks and all that
but the creative applications are really
really interesting and I think for
people who have even like just that
fingernails grip on the technology and
can connect their way through the code
and also have again maybe the
temperament to
think it's interesting and not like rise
if the machines
it's like totally wide open like just
believe Skyy interesting stuff so I
would definitely like to try to write a
novel and I'm in the process of trying
to write a novel that has kind of part
of its text the product of some of these
machine learning systems but it's you
know it's tricky because you want it to
be good you don't want it to just be a
sort of parlor trick like did you read
the machine learning novel no but I'm
aware of it and it's very interesting
like you don't want that you actually
want to produce something that's yeah
good and like worth people's time and
like interesting and worthwhile to read
but you want to do it or at least in
part using these tools that kinda no one
has ever used before so it's a cool
challenge mm-hmm have you tried to
magenta yet
um I well magenta is not really like a
thing thing it's like the suite of
different tools right they are really
focused on sound like mostly music stuff
it's really cool I actually think I
think they're one of the sort of the few
people slash groups that are doing it
right people on the podcast people on
the podcast you know I'm making air
quotes if you're getting it right and
that's only to say they're super
competent technically and interested in
kind of pushing the state of the art in
that in that sort of very cody sort of
academic ii sense but they're also very
clearly just interested in like
aesthetics like they they measure you
can tell that they're they're measuring
their own judging their own output not
unlike well we've achieved a new state
of the art of 2.7 bits on the loss
you're like cool is that better they're
like they're like looking at the end
they're looking at that sort the
qualitative like well is it does it
sound interesting is it lovely could it
be lovely and they're also this is
actually the best part they're building
tools right it's not just rock code
they're like building these things for
people to use and very clearly like
learning how to use them themselves kind
of in public in real time and I just
admire the hell out of that whenever I
see it I think it ends up offending a
lot of artists because so many of these
uh
imagery creation things in particular
are like style content transferred see
right
doesn't matter we can just throw it on
anything right exactly yeah yeah it is
and there's something about that stuff
that is I mean it's it's exciting in its
own way but it is at the same time a
little tasteless and a little bit like
oh really that's what you think it is
you think it's just like you think you
think van Gogh is swirly trees okay come
to the museum with me I there's some
things we need to talk about but it is
like I think making something that you
can learn that you can use is kind of
the key there is a lot of this code
including some of the style transfer
stuff or you kind of like the only way
to use it is to kind of say run like do
your thing tell me when you're done
which is that's a good starting point I
do think that the challenge or that kind
of the next step that gets really
interesting is learning to make tools or
even instruments that like a person can
get better at which is not easy to do I
mean people try to invent instruments
and oft like musical instruments and
often you're like there's just not
enough depth there you're like yeah I
can play Hot Cross Buns and like and
that's all you know I get this is no
viola or like this is no you know since
you know cool Moog synthesizer or
whatever and I think that's coming for
the machine learning stuff or it should
be hmm what do you think's missing right
now well I mean I mean this is a little
self agonizing but I'll describe one of
the products that I did which i think is
a tiny tiny step in that direction so
there's these neural networks that
operate on text and they can essentially
learn these statistical models of text
such that given the beginning of a
sentence they can just keep writing it
for you right and they end up course of
course being sort of wacky and
nonsensical but they really do learn
something like if you train this
internal network on all of Harry Potter
and you start a sentence like the boy
walked into thee it'll say castle where
he picked up his wand and like no that's
the following spell like it really and
like and in the style of JK Rowling
again a really actually in an impeccable
sort of imitation of the style of JK
Rowling or whoever so um
you've been able to kind of do that on
the command line for a while and there's
you know people written blog post about
like oh look I wrote some Moby Dick or
here's a weird fake Shakespeare which
are really cool I took that
stuff kind of changed the way it works a
little bit I thought hard about the
corpus I wanted to use like what I want
to get the what style I wanted to be
learning but then I also built a little
plugin for the atom text editor who's
really easy to extend use like kind of
designed to have things modded on to it
and so now instead of it being this kind
of command-line thing you're typing in a
window just as you would as you'd be
like composing a manuscript and you hit
tab the way you would to like
autocomplete something man line and a
little wheel spins for just a second and
then it goes pop and it shows you the
completion but it's not just you don't
have to just take what the computer
gives you you just as you can with
autocomplete on the on the command line
you can arrow up an arrow down through
other and so but I think this is really
important it's like the core the core
interesting thing is the weird sort of
wonderful output of this machine right
but at the same time you acknowledge
that having a human kind of curate it
and shape it and form it and just be in
the loop and be learning how to use it
is just as important hmm so and it's and
it turns out you mean artistic value
aside is really fun it's actually really
fun yeah totally
yeah well you see it on Twitter with the
autocomplete keyboard all the time just
like just tap the next thing and totally
totally to take a Harry Potter tangent
for a second early on in the book you
talk about our generation wanting to be
sorted is that it's like a strong
opinion or a throwaway line no it is
that's funny this if anything for you to
mention yeah so so the whole line is the
character says you know I'm a child of
Hogwarts and like like everyone else in
my generation I'm a child of Hogwarts
and more than anything I think we just
want to be sorted when I read that I was
like that's very true of me at least in
my early twenties someone tell me what
to do tell you exactly tell me what club
I belong to you give me my give me my
shawl my cardigan in the right colors
and let's let's just get this over with
yeah so so I do I do believe it I think
there's something to it however more
than anything else that line has been a
window for me into like what reading is
in the 21st century
mm-hmm because in part because it's near
the beginning of the book in part
because it's like a very yeah hashtag
relatable you know it's not about
a book you can kind of you can pull it
out very easily and kind of stands on
its own and because apparently it resume
with a lot of people people have taken
so many pictures of that line and that
page on Twitter on Instagram I could I
could compile you a gallery of like
hundreds of snapshots from around the
country in the world of people and like
and then with a caption just like you
know quote of the day or like oh man
Robyn slow and really gets me or like I
gotta admit this would hit really close
to home or whatever they're kind of
they're putting their little spin on it
but just to see the way like a book
becomes a social object like that and
it's this thing for them to both
ofcourse just like everything else in
social media they're like announcing
that they're reading a book which is
like pretty cool they're they're sharing
something that resonated with them
they're promoting the book a little bit
which is cool I definitely know I'm like
yes and beefer to say what book that is
from sourdough if I wrap this loan from
MCD and published on you know October
whatever so it's cool it's actually been
like almost like you know how they put
like radioactive dye total in your blood
to like a trace whatever that's been my
like dye tracer through is there one
later in the book there are a couple
thing there are a couple things that
people like a young kindle highlights
you can see what people liked but
honestly there's no other line that had
that like that became like truly like a
social object that that lept off the
page and then just kind of went off on
its own and it's so fascinating because
it doesn't really tie back into the the
rest of the book for the most part it
stands on its own yeah it's really it's
kind of it's the starting point as to
how this character feels before she even
gets to San Francisco or embroiled in
this world of food or learns any of this
weird stuff but yeah apparently there's
a lot of people in the world who feel
the same way that this character does as
the story opens have you seen a
long-form fiction change as social media
like influences at cat and I were
talking about this in the context of
museums right you know you have these
like Instagram museums basically are
they're like Instagram books with all
these like zingers yeah that's a good
question I so I don't know for sure
that's a it's a big question actually in
a really interesting one I don't really
think so not yet and I think that's for
a couple reasons of high tech kind of
just just guess one is um the truth is
that the readership for
books I mean it's obviously diverse and
like there's a lot of young people who
read books there's also a lot of older
people who read books and I think
there's a certain kind of point at which
and its course not like these people
aren't on Facebook they are like
everyone's on Facebook but I think
they're also kind of not they're like
people who just mmm relate to the world
and get information and kind of select
their media in a different way I don't
know if it's a more old-fashioned way
exactly but it's just different they
like go to the library and get a stack
of books which is by the way one of the
reasons I love like publishing books and
reaching this audience this way I think
it's like really special to be able to
talk to them in a way that like no one
on Twitter ever will because it's just
kind of you know sort of separated
worlds with not a lot of bridges between
them so I think that's part of it and I
do think that people read books for
different reasons than they use social
media still that could change that could
change over time but yeah I think books
the good books really do they're that
sort of sense of engrossment is that
even a word
yeah engrossing they're engrossing okay
yeah so epic 2014 what's your
explanation boy that's it well it's kind
of the original media experiment for me
I mean there's been so many along the
way like apps and web projects and you
know weird books and things other things
like that
epic 2014 boy it was an artifact of its
time it was 2003 to 2004 I guess is when
it finally got published I was working
in a place called the pointer Institute
in st. Petersburg Florida it was kind of
like journalism school and think-tank
really really cool institution my
colleague there was another young
journalist or sort of journalist in
training named Matt Thompson who has
gone on to become the executive editor
of the Atlantic Monthly so Wow
little did I realize um no that's not
you actually I did suspect that that was
probably gonna be his path um even back
then
so we're down in the computer lab with
wonderful I mean it wasn't quite a Mack
SC with whatever system seven but they
were some funky you know translucent
IMAX down on the computer lab and we
were frustrated because we at that time
is like this is the rise of the blog's
it's really like the
early blog boom and we were part of it
we thought it was so exciting
we thought all the stuff was so exciting
and it did not seem to us like that
people were talking to in the newspaper
industry primarily then like saw what we
saw and we tried to explain it we tried
to like give presentations with charts
and things like that and still just like
we were getting these like glazed
overlooks and we're like come on like
first all these people need to
understand this and second it's it's
exciting like there's like this is this
is if not good news it's like great
interesting news so this is where it's
almost a little cliche we're like how
can we communicate this vividly to
people by telling a story in flash we're
like we're like okay we're gonna make
this video it's gonna be this sort of
faux future documentary that tells the
the future history of media from 2004 to
2014 with all this weird stuff that
happened you know consolidation and the
New York Times goes out of business and
there's just like all this customized
news and it's it's it's all feels very
antique now in fact but um was radical a
radical vision in 2000 before but but
the great constraint of course is then
she doesn't pour you could not post
video on the internet there was like
there was no place to do it and if by
chance you did find some server space
the resulting bandwidth bill would like
crush you there were these stories
almost like urban legends of like oh
yeah Craig posted a video when times and
people watched it he had to sell his
house so the bandwidth efficient way of
sharing moving pictures was flash so we
offered this whole funky thing in flash
she was just like strange stuttering
animation and it was it was actually the
the web we have lost like the lamented
early web even the flash video was kind
of like a bit much because it became
very popular so I got weird early viral
web hit especially kind of among used
people and it go so we were kind of
feeling the burn and this server would
go down sometimes
so some friendly people with web servers
around the world but send these emails
like hello my name is Ivo I'm in the
Netherlands I would be happy to mirror a
flash movie and we were like yes here
here's the link please mirror it so on
the main page it was it was beautiful it
was like this United Nations of hosting
and there this list of like here's some
other mirrors you know and you click and
you'd go to this sort of other copy of
the page on some server in the
Netherlands oh man it was amazing that's
so cool have you thought about doing
another one you know every so often
someone asks most recently was 2014
which was kind of the crux of the of the
movie that we made more than a decade
ago and we got some some you know
feelers from people including like media
companies that were like it'll be a big
thing it'll be like our cool
well like produce it it'll be rad and
you know we'll pay you for it and all
this stuff and both of us had the same
instinct which was like it was so that
project was so guileless it was so I
mean he was pure yeah you were just like
these two 20-something people were like
people seem people don't seem to see
this as clearly as we do
perhaps if we tell a story and we had no
other expectations for it beyond that
and you just can't if you would do
something like that
and it works and it's successful that is
100% your signal to close put it on the
Shelf say what luck and move on to
something else
fair enough SOPA number came out how
many five yeah 2012 um and so I think
you know working you know I was in you
know at Wired and then yeah and then in
New York and I think around the twenty
twelve timeframe like there was so much
positivity about tech all right yeah
especially in the press and so it's
changed a lot so how did that like
change in tone in the coverage of tech
like impact the way that you talk like
write about it now that's a great
question I will let you in on something
that shift was happening of course it's
ongoing enjoys in flux that particular
shift that sort of darkening almost of
the tint was happening even as I was
kind of wrapping up the manuscript for
penumbra and I remember very vividly at
the last few passes in the summer of
2012 before it came out that fall going
through and changing a few lines that I
mean the book is very it is very kind of
like magical Silicon Valley Wonderland
there were a few lines in that original
manage kept there were even a bit much
then in 2012 and I was like people are
gonna think I'm lame and just like and
again in naive if I include this sort of
line in sorry I even even if
time and even at that point in the
process I was like I need to kind of
calibrate this a little differently
which is and that's the risk it's the
it's the fun part but also kind of the
risk in the burden of trying to write
fiction that's set now in our world
today I mean there's definitely like you
understand why people write historical
novels because there's like a refuge in
life it's not gonna it there's other
challenges but at least it won't kind of
shift underneath my feet I definitely
had to change the tone for the new one
for sourdough part of it was just just
kind of natural like the way I think
about it of course has changed over time
like everyone else we're just um yeah
it's just all about kind of power and
and the way these things have had their
role in our lives have changed so I
think any like thinking human has a
different relationship to it now and
then of course I always wanted to just
like not do another version of the same
postcard from Silicon Valley but like
send a different one so yeah the the
character in this new one and she starts
the book in a much darker place like
she's working at this robot Factory that
wants to change the world and like
transform the conditions of human labor
but their labor that they are
undertaking to do all that is like
pretty intense and she's frustrated and
strung out and not eating well
definitely not drinking enough water and
and that's yeah that's so in some ways I
wanted to I wanted to make it feel like
a dispatch from Silicon Valley today
without taking the I think easy route of
just like burn it all down that you see
elsewhere cuz I don't think that's well
first of all other people have got that
covered
they've other people are fully on the
burn it all down beat and that's good
I mean it's it's we need them out there
so maybe I could do a little something
different
that's great all right thanks for coming
in Robin thanks for the invitation is
real treat cool
you